wenn du das siehst ich gehe auf jeden
fall günstiger wird von ihm seine krone
und du musst ja gar keine angst machen
[Musik]
hallo auf jeden fall befinden uns gerade
durch dänemark schweden und norwegen ich
was vergessen perfekt wir sind jetzt
gestern losgefahren von köln aus
richtung hamburg kam dann in der nähe
von haben wir gezählt hat und die
landschaft ist es schon mal richtig geil
hier so dieser tor
also diese gebäude und man merkt auf
jeden fall dass wir jetzt im norden
befinden wo ich würde echt richtig schön
[Musik]
wir können mittlerweile in dänemark und
200 pro tag dass er planen wir
eigentlich gewesen dass wir uns vor der
brücke treffen mit der anderen hälfte
und truppe die wir jetzt dann gleich
kennenlernen ihr wisst ja noch gar nicht
entscheiden mit wem wir unterwegs sind
das ist zum einen maler franz genau dass
er ist der der philippinen kenne ja
schon christophori ist sebastian
sebastian
[Musik]
leute wir sind jetzt gerade in porton
fahren gekommen nachdem wir ja die nacht
noch den irgendwo gezählt wir suchen
jetzt ein bisschen was zum besten die an
einen tisch und ich bin hierhin
geschickt und hier ist halt warten denn
ein bisschen einheimisches essen etwas
essen wenn in spanien wo wird sich
erinnern kaviar im zehnten spiel
einfahren
genau das wollen wir
[Musik]
einheimische top fashion sprachen lernen
und das und das und das und das und das
ist das was ich will gar nicht gemacht
herr lokal wir sind jetzt auf jeden fall
durch mit kopenhagen ist echt übel
galten schon richtig heiß nun denn jetzt
geht es weiter richtung schweden ich
glaube richtung nicht in richtung hd
richtung stockholm malmö vorbei wenn wir
es wieder ein stückchen rumcruisen und
auch davon dass ihr bargeld anders
[Musik]
so leute wir sind jetzt gerade bei einem
übrigen bin ich für euch einfach mal
guckt euch das mal an jetzt mal ist er
mit dieser droge
und jetzt hoffe ich mal dass dies leider
nicht abstürzt weil die alte ohne
probleme habe ich auch wissen war
[Musik]
hey hey wir sehen gerade in schweden
immer noch an einem riesigen see und wir
haben diesen geilen scott entdeckt will
der wird gerade schon ins wasser
das sind fossilien auf jeden fall unser
plan ist es jetzt auf jeden fall hier
eine gala tonaufnahme zu starten
[Musik]
in diesem jahr wollen jetzt so ein
bisschen ein signal geben oder nicht ich
gehe auf jeden fall erwünscht ist würden
mit einem kunden ohne uns ja gar keine
angst zu den wir die ganze zeit abfallen
wären wir gerade mit dem auto gefahren
durch schweden jetzt im moment der kommt
von den fans der ist luxus und der hat
jetzt gerade neue pr ausgetobt und video
geschlagen da kann in den auszeiten
lohnt sich auf jeden fall derzeit
bedient gibt dem ein bisschen liebe ist
gerade auf den weg zu legen so einem see
wo wir dann wieder unseren zelt
aufschlagen werden
[Musik]
manchmal schmeckt gut die aufgaben und
setzt ein bisschen was zu essen gemacht
haben wieder unsere zelte aufgebaut
haben eben noch ein bisschen gebäude an
der stelle werde ich den blog aber es
gibt noch so viel zu sehen dass ich mir
denke dass ich das in mehrere teile
aufteilen werden natürlich auch nicht
dazu kommen den block noch im urlaub zu
schneiden deswegen ist es jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon irgendwann mit der
august oder sogar kleine jetzt schon
september ist das video online komme auf
jeden fall oder so zugesehen habe sich
auch die hauptpersonen keinen tag und
sehen uns beim nächsten teil der reise
wieder und ab weil sie begleiten würdet
und wieder ab oder lassen
[Musik]